oh you you always have to have a backup
plan in case it doesn't work out like
there's a lot of rhetoric that is
anti-family that it goes against the
family this idea that men are abusive
you always have to have a backup plan
you have to wait to get married is is
anti all of that is anti-family and I
also think they had women start going to
colleges because if women go to college
Christians that go to college there's a
70 chance that they are no longer
Christian
70 so they basically take all the Jesus
out of the women and have them go into
the workforce and
basically break down the family so and
it's funny because we get all of this
power and freedom without the
responsibility of paying the taxes and
running the infrastructure of society